Wahlberg, born the youngest of nine children
all living in a three bedroom apartment, dropped
out of school around the age of fourteen and
joined a gang.
During this time, he was reportedly in trouble
with the law around 20-25 times, for dealing
drugs and various other offenses.
He also claims he became addicted to cocaine
during this period.
Things came to a head when he was 16 years
old and he attacked two Vietnamese men without
provocation.
He attacked the first with a stick and he
punched the second, permanently blinding him
in the process.
The official record of the event as recorded
by the Commonwealth of Massachusetts Superior
Court is as follows:
Count I:
At approximately 9:00 p.m. on April 8, 1988,
Thanh Lam, a Vietnamese adult male who resides
in Dorchester, traveled by car to 998 Dorchester
Avenue, Dorchester, Massachusetts.
At 998 Dorchester Avenue, Thanh Lam left his
car carrying two cases of beer.
As he crossed the sidewalk, Mark Wahlberg
attacked Thanh Lam.
Wahlberg was carrying a large wooden stick,
approximately five feet long and two to three
inches in diameter.
Wahlberg approached Thanh Lam calling him
a “Vietnam fucking shit”, then hit him
over the head with the stick.
Thanh Lam was knocked to the ground unconscious.
The stick broke in two and was later recovered
from the scene.
Thanh Lam was treated overnight at Boston
City Hospital.
After police arrested Wahlberg later on the
night of April 8, 1988, Wahlberg was informed
of his rights and returned to the scene of
988 Dorchester Avenue.
In the presence of two police officers, he
stated: “You don’t have to let him identify
me, I’ll tell you now that’s the mother-fucker
whose head I split open”, or words to that
effect.
Count II:
As a police officer arrived at the scene of
988 Dorchester Avenue, Wahlberg and two other
youths who were with him fled up Dorchester
Avenue toward Pearl Street.
Shortly after 9:00pm on April 8, 1988, Hoa
Trinh, an adult Vietnamese male who resides
in Dorchester, was standing several blocks
away from 998 Dorchester Avenue, near the
corner of Dorchester Avenue and Pearl Street.
Hoa Trinh was not aware of the altercation
outside of 998 Dorchester Avenue.
Wahlberg ran up to Hoa Trinh, put his arm
around Hoa Trinh’s shoulder and said: “Police
coming, police coming, let me hide.”
After a police cruiser passed, Wahlberg punched
Trinh in the eye, causing him to fall to the
ground.
Police arrived and Hoa Trinh identified Wahlberg
as the person who punched him.
Wahlberg was placed under arrest and read
his rights.
Thereafter, he made numerous unsolicited racial
statements about “gooks” and “slant-eyed
gooks”.
After being returned to 998 Dorchester Avenue,
Wahlberg identified Thanh Lam as the person
he hit over the head with a stick.
For these attacks, Wahlberg was arrested and
initially charged with attempted murder, but
it was later reduced to criminal contempt,
which carried a maximum sentence of ten years.
After pleading guilty, he was given a two
year sentence at the Deer Island House of
Correction in Boston.
In the end, he only had to serve 45 days in
the correctional facility.
Unlike most that go through such facilities,
the time he spent locked up inspired him to
try and turn his life around.
“As soon as I began that life of crime,
there was always a voice in my head telling
me I was going to end up in jail.
Three of my brothers had done time.
My sister went to prison so many times I lost
count.
Finally I was there, locked up with the kind
of guys I’d always wanted to be like.
Now I’d earned my stripes and I was just
like them and I realized it wasn’t what
I wanted at all.
I’d ended up in the worst place I could
possibly imagine and I never wanted to go
back.”
He started his turn-around by reaching out
to his parish priest for guidance and support,
as well as leaving the gang he was a member
of.
Mark Wahlberg’s big break came thanks to
his older brother, Donnie.
Donnie Wahlberg was already famous at this
point with his success as a member of The
New Kids on the Block, a band Mark had initially
been a member of at the age of 13, but quit
before the group became famous.
Mark had been working as a bricklayer after
serving time when Donnie helped him form Marky
Mark and the Funky Bunch, including helping
him get a record contract and producing the
first record the group made.
The debut album Music for the People, released
in 1991 when Mark Wahlberg was 19 years old,
ended up going Platinum thanks largely to
the hit single Good Vibrations and the follow
up single Wildside.
After his music career started to hit the
tank a couple years later, Wahlberg dropped
his Marky Mark persona and decided to take
up acting.
Despite early skepticism by critics, he made
the switch successfully, with his first critical
success coming from appearing in The Basketball
Diaries, though he had a few roles before
this, most notably opposite Danny DeVito in
Renaissance Man.
Since then, he has become one of the bigger
stars in Hollywood, reportedly commanding
around $12-$15 million per movie today.
During his “Marky Mark” fame period, Wahlberg
famously worked for Calvin Klein as an underwear
model.
Somewhat more humorously, he also put out
a workout video: Form…
Focus…
Fitness
Mark Wahlberg’s siblings are: Arthur, James,
Debbie, Michelle, Paul, Tracey, Robert, and
Donnie.
He also has half siblings Scott, Buddy, and
Donna who are children of his dad by another
woman.
Though all in all Wahlberg has turned his
life around quite nicely, especially in recent
years where he’s been involved in numerous
charitable endeavors, particularly benefiting
underprivileged youth, he still had several
instances of violence in his post-prison,
younger years (around the “Marky Mark”
period).
For instance, when he was 21 years old, he
“viciously and repeatedly kicked the plaintiff,
Robert D. Crehan, in the face and jaw” while
a friend of his, Derk McCall, held Crehan
down on the ground.
This resulted in Crehan’s jaw being broken,
as well as a claimed decrease in learning
ability.
Wahlberg also famous had a fight with certain
members of Madonna’s entourage (which he
states Madonna still owes him an apology over).
He also attacked a security guard, which resulted
in him having to appear in several anti-bias
advertisements.
Wahlberg states about his early life: “I’ve
made a lot of mistakes in my life and I’ve
done bad things.
But I never blamed my upbringing for that.
I never behaved like a victim so that I would
have a convenient reason for victimizing others.
Everything I did wrong was my own fault.
I was taught the difference between right
and wrong at an early age.
I take full responsibility.”
Wahlberg was originally cast in both Ocean’s
Eleven and Brokeback Mountain, but turned
both roles down.
In Ocean’s Eleven, he was cast as Linus
Caldwell, but withdrew and Matt Damon was
cast instead.
In Brokeback Mountain he states he withdrew
due to being uncomfortable with the sex scenes.
Wahlberg and several friends originally had
tickets to fly on United 93, one of the planes
hijacked by terrorists on September 11, 2001.
However, they ended up deciding to instead
charter a plane to go attend a film festival
in Canada before returning to Los Angeles.
Wahlberg has since stated that “If I was
on that plane with my kids, it wouldn’t
have went down like it did.
There would have been a lot of blood in that
first-class cabin and then me saying, ‘OK,
we’re going to land somewhere safely, don’t
worry.'”
Obviously this didn’t go over very well
with people who lost loved ones on that plane,
nor with the general public.
Given Wahlberg’s apparent propensity towards
violence, even when unprovoked, the first
part of his claim isn’t really that far-fetched.
However, the passengers of United 93 did revolt
once they realized the bomb threat the terrorists
were using to control them wasn’t likely
true.
They learned this after several passengers
heard of the planes that hit the twin towers
from talking to loved ones on their cell phones.
Unfortunately for the passengers, though,
the terrorists at this point were obviously
the ones flying the plane.
Once the passengers had nearly broken into
the cockpit, the hijackers made the decision
to simply crash the plane, with one recorded
as saying “Is that it?
I mean, shall we put it down?” and another
responding, “Yes, pull it down.”
The pilot then rolled the plane over and began
chanting “Allāhu Akbar”, while the passengers
continued to fight.
The official report states that at the time
of impact, the passengers were just seconds
from taking complete control.
So obviously Wahlberg with his temper and
fighting ability being there or not would
have made no difference as the hijackers would
have put the plane down all the same the second
it was apparent a passenger or group of passengers
were about to retake the aircraft.
Wahlberg never returned to High School after
dropping out at the age of 14, but did eventually
get his GED.
Since New Kids on the Block, Donnie Wahlberg
also took up acting, appearing in such works
as Band of Brothers, the Saw films, and The
Sixth Sense.
For the latter role in The Sixth Sense as
“Vincent Grey”, he had to lose 43 pounds.
New Kids on the Block was formed by Maurice
Starr who held auditions in Boston with over
500 boys turning out.
The first member selected was Donnie Wahlberg,
who subsequently convinced Starr to also add
Mark to the group, along with some friends
of his.
New Kids on the Block actually almost never
were, as far as becoming famous.
Their debut album was a flop and their second
album initially didn’t do any better.
After their first album, the group could only
get gigs at school dances and the like.
When their second album was released, it also
initially flopped with little interest in
their first single Please Don’t Go Girl.
Finally, the label had decided to drop the
group, but at this same time a single radio
station in Florida had been playing the song
steadily, with it becoming one of the most
requested songs at that station.
When Columbia Records learned of this, they
decided to promote the song more and things
took off from there.
Interestingly, due to their later success,
their debut album ultimately ended up selling
four million copies, despite the initial flop.
All total, New Kids on the Block sold over
70 million albums.
The original name of New Kids on the Block
was “NYNUK”, but upon signing the group,
the label, Columbia Records, told them they
needed to come up with a different name.
Donnie Wahlberg also has had his share of
trouble with the law, such as being charged
with first degree arson for setting fire to
a hotel hallway in Kentucky (The Seelbach
Hotel).
The charges were later lowered and he simply
had to make a series of public service ads
about fire safety, as well as anti-drug and
anti-drunk driving ads.